What I'm doing is called beat juggling.
So, essentially you're taking one record and putting it on both turntables.
So while this one plays, I'm getting this one ready to start back over the beginning of a loop.
Sean Johnson is in an advanced mixing class, his final course at the Beat Refinery.
He's been taking evening classes at the DJ school outside Washington for about two years.
By day, he works as an audio engineer.
I don't do that full-time anymore.
I'm slowly working my way into being a full-time DJ.
It is really just kind of making a dream come to life.
Twelve-year-old Ethan Feinberg has been taking classes here for a year and a half.
Well, I want to be a DJ when I am older, and I really like music.
And it's fun.
We have 10-year-olds all the way up to 50-year-olds.
Women, men, all nationalities, sometimes we've had students that can't even speak English...
...but there is the music that brings them together.
Longtime DJ Chris Stiles cofounded the Beat Refinery in 2010.
It is the only DJ school in the Washington area.
We felt that there was a need to have the school...
...because in today's world you see a lot of different places where people use DJs...
...whether it's at weddings or at bars, clubs or clothing stores.
The profession of a DJ has become a very sought-after job.
The school offers classes for those wanting to become professionals...
...as well as those who just want to mix party music for friends.